what's going on guys in this video i've
selected
five characters from black clover and
we're going to examine what it would be
like if they were born
in the micro academia universe instead
if you've watched both series you'll
know there's a massive difference
in the power systems of black clover and
my hero academia so that means in this
video there will be
no spirits no devils and definitely no
grimoires involved
if we can get this video to 5 000 likes
then i'll drop a part 2 with different
characters from black clover
as soon as humanly possible don't forget
to sub for more anime crossovers like
this
and remember i do a live commentary of
black clover and my hero chapters
every sunday on twitch to start things
off we have the pro hero
known as blackout aka yami sukihiro
yami is a 28 year old pro hero who ranks
83rd on the charts
and his quirk is called dark matter this
power grants him the ability to generate
darkness
and manipulate it in various ways at its
most basic level
this quirk enables him to cancel out all
light sources
within a 200 meter radius whether it be
light bulbs candles
phones or anything else if something
generates light then dark matter can
stop it from doing so
making yami a really useful hero when it
comes to raids
or stealth missions he always carries a
trusty katana as a support item
which he can then charge up with
darkness that he generates from his body
this allows him to perform a wide
variety of dark powered slashes and
thrusts
capable of tearing the fabric of space
he's also able to use darkness to
restrain his enemies
and maneuver himself around which is not
too dissimilar from another character in
this universe
yami also has a black hole technique in
which he generates enough dark matter to
create an
endless void that absorbs enemy attacks
this is the ultimate defense against
long-range quirks
and can protect yami and his allies as
attacks are immediately
sucked into it the only real weakness is
that dark matter takes a while to
generate compared to other emitter
quarks
which can sometimes leave the hero in a
vulnerable position
moving on we have yuno who is one of the
top three students in class 1a
and has a level of natural talent that
is just off the charts
juno's quirk is wind control and it
makes him virtually untouchable
thanks to this power he is constantly
able to read the air currents around him
which lets you know sense any movement
even when someone's not in his line of
sight
this means he can visualize where people
are which gives him senses nearly on par
with hawks's detection skills that said
yuno's main ability is similar to that
of inasa from shiketsu high
in that he can manipulate gusts of wind
for his own purpose
and generate tornadoes capable of wiping
out a city block
yuno surpasses inessa in various ways in
particular his speed and precision when
it comes to wind control
allows him to create things that are
generally not seen in nature
this includes sharp bursts of wind that
can pierce through an enemy like a sword
or concentrated blasts of wind that blow
the enemy away
similar to air cannon his wing control
is also very handy for transportation
as he often flies through the air like a
true superhero
or he carries along people for the ride
which is always useful in disaster
situations
in all aspects yuno is a near perfect
all-rounder
and he has no significant weaknesses
other than his lack of experience
at this point next up we have the pro
hero known
as dreamscape but her real name is
dorothy unsworth
she ranked 42nd place on the last hero
charts and is part of a renowned hero
team
with midnight dreamscape controls an
infinite imaginary world
in which literally anything she imagines
is manifested
i know you may be thinking that you too
have an imaginary world
but the difference is that dorothy can
actually send people's consciousnesses
there
and do anything to them with no physical
consequences
once someone is in the dream world she
can create anything
living or non-living whether it be
monsters people
giant furniture whatever you name it she
can make it
it should be stated that dreamscape
herself does not have to be asleep to
enter the dream world
because it exists in her imagination
which she can obviously access while
she's awake just like anyone else
her targets however do have to be asleep
and there are
three main ways that she gets people to
enter this world
number one is that midnight will put
people to sleep and then dreamscape will
activate her quirk once she's within
a 10 meter range of the target option
number two is that she can knock out her
target completely
whether it be by a punch or some other
kind of physical attack
her final option is perhaps the longest
and basically she has to focus her eyes
on the target
whilst counting up to 50 sheep in her
mind this is not a technique that she
often uses on the battlefield because
it just takes way too long and it leaves
her vulnerable because she can't divert
her eyes away from the target
it does however come in useful when
she's trying to extract information from
people who are
already restrained including a certain
vegetable
last thing to mention on this character
is that she can use her quirk on someone
who just fell asleep naturally
although she considers this to be
cheating and doesn't do it too often
following on from this we have the
silver eagle aka nozelle silva
his quirk is called liquid metal and
it's arguably the most adaptable quirk
of any hero
with this ability he can generate vast
amounts of mercury from his body
and then manipulate it to help him in
any situation
nozell can harden his mercury at will
and so he often does this to create
these near
impenetrable shields while
simultaneously attacking the enemy with
spears or bullets because mercury is so
dense
nozzle can wipe out hordes of enemies in
one go with his silver reign which
builds momentum as it falls back down to
earth on the other hand
nozelle can target enemies more
precisely with his silver shining spear
which is when a concentrated beam of
mercury explodes from his hand
and is then manipulated to cause maximum
damage
even after the initial blow his mastery
and precision with this quirk is further
demonstrated
by how he can restrain enemies either by
trapping them in an intricate cage made
from mercury
or by encasing their body in liquid
metal and then hardening it
he is incredibly versatile and
essentially he is equivalent to a team
of heroes
just by himself last but certainly not
least
the final character is astor from class
1b whose quirk origin is a bit of a
mystery
the name of astor's quirk is black mass
and it allows an otherworldly energy to
flow through his body
which he can then use for various
purposes including erasing the quirks of
others
enhancing his weapons physical
reinforcements
and flight being an expert swordsman
astor often imbues black mass into
whichever sword he's using at the time
with his preferred choice being this
giant one right here
starting with his main ability astor can
temporarily nullify the quirk factor
of any person he touches with black mass
with the exception being mutation quirks
usually he erases quirks by whacking
people with his sword
but he could just erase quirks with his
hands if he wanted to
once he makes contact the victim's quirk
is erased for 60 seconds
and astor can't nullify their quirk any
further until the original 60 seconds is
over
additionally this power can negate any
projectile attack
for example he could slash three
minetta's balls which would cause
all of the balls to pop simultaneously
or he could take a swing at endeavour's
flames
which would stop the fire immediately he
can also manipulate this quirk
to extend the reach of his sword without
adding any weight to it which is
pretty convenient black mass is also
good for physical reinforcements
as asta can activate his black aster
mode
in this state asda temporarily becomes
superhuman
with his mind entering a state of
enhanced focus
and his body being capable of flight for
a few minutes
he can only use this form for a couple
times a day and for about five minutes
each time
so this is more of a trump card that he
uses if he has no other choice
even without this black form though asta
has incredible perception of his
surroundings
and is able to react to enemies with
frightening precision
overall he has a ton of potential and
i'm sure he must have worked a few class
1a students
during the sports festival and with that
done those are what these five
characters from the black clever anime
would be like if they were in my here
academia be sure to smash that like
button
as i have a few more characters in mind
that we should do if
there's a part two and until the next
one peace out